There is a great place if you are into rock climbing.
Mount Penteli near Athens offers fabulous opportunities for rock climbing and abseiling.
Several crags are available for sport and traditional mountain climbing...
...on marble because the rock quality is really good.
There is an interesting story about the Ntavelis Cave in this mountain.
The cave is a huge underground hall with tunnel systems...
...leading to a small underground lake and a temple to the ancient god Pan.
The cave is reportedly the source of some very weird supernatural happenings...
...strange noises, small humanoids, ozone smells, loss of electrical power, and disappearances.
Measurements found abnormalities in the magnetic field.
The area was closed when NATO moved in for awhile...
...during the building of a tunnel system.
After that, it emerged that a few workers had died of cancer.
Some people believe that this cave is a gateway to another dimension.